nuclear fusion is not the most
understood energy source in the world
yet it could be one of the most useful
in the next few years when i found that
out i thought i'd take you down the
rabbit hole of nuclear fusion as i
explore the largest fusion reactor in
the world the world's largest nuclear
fusion project the international
thermonuclear experimental reactor
project or eta is a collaborative
nuclear fusion project of 35 nations
aimed at reproducing the energy that
fuels the sun by building the world's
largest tokamak what is tokamak you ask
i'll tell you more about it later in the
video so stick around located in the
south of france in a commune called sao
paulo de ross the nuclear fusion
research and engineering mega project is
estimated to be worth 22 billion
every day thousands of scientists and
engineers combine resources from 35
nations to tackle one of the most
ambitious energy projects on earth in
one of the most diverse workplaces but
before diving deep into the eta project
let's learn a bit more about nuclear
fusion and how it differs from the
standard nuclear power plants currently
used to generate electricity in many
countries what is nuclear fusion nuclear
fusion is a process where two light
atomic nuclei combine to release energy
not to be confused with nuclear fission
which is the process of splitting two
heavy unstable atomic nuclei into two
lighter nuclei releasing energy in the
process as well nuclear fusion unlike
fission releases more energy making it a
more powerful process perhaps the most
important distinction between fusion and
fission is that fusion does not create
harmful radioactive by-products that
need to be stored for thousands of years
currently all nuclear power plants use
the process of nuclear fission in order
to generate electricity as i mentioned
the process produces radioactive waste
that must be safely stored over long
periods fusion on the other hand
produces the noble gas helium though it
is yet to be achieved on a large scale
the process of nuclear fusion is a lot
cleaner and way less messy if eta
succeeds in achieving stable nuclear
fusion it will undoubtedly be one of the
most significant scientific
breakthroughs of the 21st century now a
fusion reaction works by forcing two
light extremely hot nuclei to merge and
create a heavier nucleus as the two fuse
together a lot of energy is released
that energy is then transferred as heat
through a water loop system to produce
steam that spins a turbine to generate
electricity theoretically the fusion
process releases energy because the
total mass of the resulting single
nucleus is less than the mass of the two
original nuclei so all the leftover mass
becomes the energy that is converted
into electricity nuclear fusion is the
same process that is going on in our sun
right now and it is the process that all
stars in our universe use to generate
heat light and energy scientists have
understood the process of nuclear fusion
for a long time but so far they have
only achieved to replicate the process
in small experimental settings and only
for fractions of seconds if they succeed
in carrying out a nuclear fusion
reaction that is self-sustaining it is
going to be humanity's solution for a
long-term sustainable clean safe and
carbon-free energy source this is the
aim of the eta project so you can see
why billions of dollars have been poured
into this project making it one of the
largest scientific experiments on earth
the eta tokamak
but the question remains how will eta
achieve this remember the tokamak that's
how at the beginning of this video i
said i would tell you more about it
later so here it goes the tokamak is a
device used in nuclear fusion for the
magnetic confinement of plasma and
control of the fusion process actually
the term tokamak is a russian acronym
that stands for a toroidal chamber with
magnetic coils which is what it is in
simple terms a tokamak essentially is a
chamber made out of a complex system of
magnetic fields that can find the plasma
of reactive charged particles as they
try to fuse together in a hollow taurus
or donut shaped container token max have
existed before but eta will be the
world's largest tokamak twice the size
of the largest machine currently in
operation scientists have been super
ambitious with this as they have
increased the volume of the plasma
chamber by a factor of 10 in comparison
to the closest rival this increased
volume will allow the eta tokamak to
undertake constant self-sustaining
nuclear fusion or at least that is the
hope but let us dive a little deeper
into how a tokamak operates and the
engineering challenge that faces eta
scientists the engineering challenge
the eater tocomac is not a simple
machine to build the construction of
this behemoth will include various
subsystems like the cryostat a device
that will encapsulate the entire system
and maintain the low cryogenic
temperatures required for fusion to
start a magnet system will line the
walls of the tocomax internal chamber to
control the plasma from the fusion
reaction behind it will be a
water-cooled blanket system to extract
the heat produced from the reaction a
diverter system will be responsible for
extracting the waste of the reaction and
finally the donut shaped vacuum vessel
where the fusion reaction will occur so
let's break down each of these
subsystems of the tokamak and see the
magnitude of engineering challenges
facing eater engineers first the eta
cryostat with an internal volume of 16
000 cubic meters is the largest high
vacuum pressure chamber ever built it
provides a high vacuum ultra cool
environment for the eater vacuum vessel
and the superconducting magnets standing
at 30 meters high and just as wide the
cryostat was manufactured from stainless
steel it weighs a total of
3850 tons its base section alone weighs
around 1 250 tons the cryostat will be
the single largest load of the eta
tokamak assembly next the eta magnet
system will also be the largest and most
integrated superconducting magnet system
ever built superconducting magnets were
chosen for this task as they were able
to carry higher currents and produce
stronger magnetic fields than
conventional counterparts they also
consume less power and are cheaper to
operate making superconducting magnetic
technology the only option for eaters
huge magnet systems in total 10 000
tonnes of magnets with a combined stored
magnetic energy of 51 gigajoules will
produce the magnetic fields that will
initiate confine shape and control the
eta plasma then the diverter system
which is situated at the bottom of the
vacuum vessel the diverter extracts heat
and ash produced by the fusion reaction
minimizes plasma contamination and
protects the surrounding walls from
thermal and neutronic loads as the
fusion reaction takes off the high
energy plasma particles will strike the
walls of the tokamak at incredible
speeds this kinetic energy will be
transformed into heat energy which will
be removed from the system by active
water cooling the eater's blanket system
will be responsible for this the blanket
system which covers a surface of 600
square meters is one of the most
critical and technically challenging
components of the eta tokamak together
with the diverter it directly faces the
hot plasma of the fusion reaction the
440 blanket modules that completely
cover the inner walls of the vacuum
vessel protect the steel structure and
the superconducting toroidal field
magnets from the heat and high energy
neutrons produced by the fusion reaction
each blanket module measures one by 1.5
meters and weighs up to 4.6 tonnes eta
will be the first fusion device to
operate with an actively water cooled
blanket the cooling water injected at 4
megapascals of pressure and at a
temperature of 70 degrees celsius is
designed to remove up to 736 megawatts
of thermal power all of these systems
are designed to support the tokamak's
main component which is the vacuum
vessel this donut shaped chamber is
probably the most important component of
the entire eater assembly this is where
the particles will be forced to fuse
together and generate a superheated
plasma as a result the eater vacuum
vessel's outer diameter will measure
19.4 meters across 11.4 meters high and
weigh approximately
200 tons with an interior volume of 1
400 cubic meters the eta vacuum vessel
will provide an absolutely unique
experimental arena for nuclear fusion
physicists as mentioned earlier the
volume of the plasma contained in the
center of the vessel is going to be 10
times larger than that of the largest
operating token mac in the world today
so everything in the eater project is
literally dialed up to 10 now the eta
project is currently under construction
on a 180 hectare site with 39 buildings
and technical areas housing the eta
tokamak and all its ancillary systems
pre-assembly of the tokamak components
takes place in an assembly hall first
before being moved to its final
destination other auxiliary buildings in
the vicinity of the tokamak building are
cooling towers electrical installations
a control room facilities for the
management of waste and the cryogenics
plant that will provide liquid helium
used within the cryostat as it stands
the eta team currently has 35 countries
involved including china the 28 states
of the european union switzerland india
japan korea russia and the united states
this ambitious project was expected to
take 10 years to build eta had
originally planned to test its first
plasma in 2020 and achieve full fusion
by 2023 however with any project of this
magnitude that tests the limits of
physics there will be delays the
schedule is now to conduct the first
test in 2025 and achieve a full
self-sustaining fusion reaction by 2035.
so what happens if it works if the eater
experiment is successful there are two
expected results first is the creation
of burning plasma which is one of the
four fundamental states of matter along
with solid liquid and gas during the
experiments if the energy of the helium
nuclei produced when hydrogen isotopes
are fused becomes large enough to
sustain and propagate the burn without
the need for external heat sources then
eta scientists would have created
burning plasma this is the first step
towards a self-sustaining nuclear fusion
reaction as the first such burning
plasma device in the world eta will
offer scientists a unique opportunity to
chart new territory and control nuclear
fusion and the second expected result of
the experiments will be proof of the
feasibility of tritium breeding which is
the ability to produce tritium within
the vacuum vessel you see the supply of
tritium which is used with deuterium to
fuel the fusion reactions is
insufficient to serve future power
plants eta is specially designed to
provide a unique opportunity to test
in-vessel tritium breeding in a real
fusion environment if it can demonstrate
this ability successfully it will be a
major step for humanity towards
achieving large-scale fusion reaction
plants in the future so a lot hangs in
the balance eta is not designed to be a
nuclear fusion power plant itself but it
is the test bed for all the future
technologies and understanding required
to operate one and if you were still in
two minds about the significance and the
magnitude of the task ahead of the eta
scientists maybe this analogy will help
simplify it for you they are literally
trying to create a mini sun within the
confines of a few buildings so what do
you guys think will the eta experiment
be a success and moreover will we see
operational nuclear fusion power plants
within the next decade let me know in
the comment section below if you enjoyed
this video hit the subscribe button and
continue watching by clicking on one of
the cards on your screen see you in the
next one